[Music]
we all know about america's rising crime
rate especially violent crime in urban
areas
but did you know that an increasing
number of these depraved acts are being
committed by young teens
fox's matt finn is in los angeles to
tell us more matt
hi laura over the past few days
extremely disturbing crimes committed by
teens in chicago three boys 14 and under
were charged with felony charges of
aggravated carjacking of a 50-year-old
man in ohio two 13-year-old boys
arrested on rape charges here in
california horrifying robbery video in
san francisco monday a chinatown camera
store three teens use a hammer trying to
smash the glass cases but they're
plexiglass and do not crack a co-owner
grabs a bat and starts swinging
neighboring workers rushed in to help
the co-owner said he got pepper sprayed
hit in the head with a hammer needing 10
stitches and in new orleans a 73 year
old grandmother was killed after her arm
was ripped off during a carjacking video
appears to show the woman innocently in
her own car when a group of teens rushed
in and carjacked her neighbors and
witnesses were screaming and tried to
intervene linda fricke's arm got caught
in the seatbelt and was severed as the
four teens drove her car away dragging
her for one block the stolen car was
recovered about 13 blocks away
and i can't say this enough
when they pulled away and she was in
that strap they made the decision to
murder her they should pay for it
new orleans police arrested four minors
for that deadly carjacking the police
superintendent wants them charged as
adults laura
matt that is so upsetting on so many
levels thank you it is joining me now is
john mcarthur grace community church
pastor
pastor macarthur uh good to see you
tonight i i immediately thought of you
because i wanted to ask you what you
thought
was at the heart of this these inner
city youth
this is happening across america how did
things get this bad
well i think you know laura that
humanity is capable of some horrendous
crimes whether it's killing a senior
citizen or
bombing
a hospital full of children in the
ukraine
and god has built into society some
restraints the first restraint
is the knowledge of god that there is a
righteous and holy judge to whom we are
accountable
that is a restraint on evil
beyond that there is the law of god
written in the heart every culture knows
what is right and wrong because
universally that's part of being created
in god's image there's the conscience
we have a society basically that has
removed god
so that transcendental restraint is gone
that has flipped morality on its head
so conscience is misinformed
the next restraint is the family
destroy the family
and there's no opportunity for
disciplined
raising of children to make them
socially capable of interacting in a
positive way
the family falls apart
and the next barrier is the police
and by then it's it's beyond them i mean
witnessed the riots last summer when the
police just stand there and watch so
it's a sequence of things where this
society the young in this society have
smashed every divine restraint down
and
it overwhelms the final
governmental institution
which is the police
and then you can add throw in how much
lawlessness there is at every level
whether it's
you know even politicians or whether
it's the immorality of heroes athletes
movie actors
the culture
is so immoral
so against the family
sow against god and you sow that and you
reap exactly what we get today
well pastor macarthur i think
people just wake up and they think how
you know how did this happen but you
just laid it out you know beautifully in
all of its you know
sad disturbing ways that this happens
over
time
and every
institution which acts as a check on the
individual is under attack or cast aside
and we have we have the results around
us i knew you would state it so so
succinctly and we really appreciate you
joining us tonight next time we'll have
you on for longer pastor thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else